the Foreman's not a technique the vessel
the timing and the spatial relationships
the patterns the great issues fulfilling
the pattern all that is trying to teach
you something so you come then this has
to fit okay what is finished well I
shouldn't be pushing or pulling if I'm
pushing or pulling that means he's doing
the opposite otherwise I can't feel the
pull or I can't feel the push you guys
bought that so that means if I feel the
flourish or the pool or they find
pushing and pulling
I'm not harmonizing Union y'all and then
I'm not doing I to do okay so he goes
that this artist doesn't feel anything
and it doesn't take any any effort to
reach him in other words you see fantasy
it's just all fits perfectly and then
the same thing with the drop doesn't
take any effort at all everything goes
and the same thing goes as he gets up
there's a timing and there's a space
where I can fit not if it takes any
energy same thing he goes where he's
going same thing it just fits
whoa this fits same thing hitting up
just fits just fits same thing just fits
so this is wrong this is gonna punch me
boom it's gonna stab me right is you did
it wrong well that wasn't a PIT maneuver
the fruit manures you don't take one now
do you eat meat any fun then you go
where there's space then you go where
this position is but you have to wait
for her in this very very this is an
extra turn because he is rooted deeper
than could pop the door
so don't just make it a free-for-all
otherwise you're not learning anything
so katate dori is telling me so he gives
a push all right so that's this is I
can't stay here because this is not
neutral you just grab and we have you
know here this is where I would say I'm
going to do something we should tell you
you must be doing something so as he
goes that's that's when i neutralize
that do you see how I'm doing that okay
so I'm looking for this to reach let's
call it zero zero is not plus one
pushing or plus one pulling got it right
it hits zero and the same thing if I
start going here that's gonna be a pull
do you see that so that's gonna be plus
one pull
it's gonna I wanted to set to say it's
zero so this grip is telling me where I
need to step at what rate at what angle
you got it and the same thing with this
hand if I move this over here you're
gonna feel a lot more mass it's not
hitting at zero so this hand has got to
be at 0 and this hands got to be at zero
and that's where I draw it it's just
zero then we go again here goes the next
problem so some of you were all here and
you're starting to lift you see that
what if you got lower then you wouldn't
have to live do you understand so pay
attention to all those things won't long
here you see and this zero again it's
zero Yankees go on that way long and
it's zero again zero same thing if I
start going this far you see this grip
now is not at zero plus one so I don't
do that same thing here if I'm pushing
on that that's plus one no rather
zero then I have the admin Thomas if I
was just to Nikko right that's where I
would end go back but I have to keep the
zero and find a new pattern so it says
zero so he's neutralized zero boom here
we go zero zero one zero and my grips
are telling me what I need to do and
when to do it how far to do it okay
you want do you want something that's
the problem
so you want him to fall something you go
plus push plus one foot you want him not
to be there so you go plus one for you
you really have to stop having an
intention and really just have a feeling
just a feeling that's all you want
that's all you want so I know he's
slowing down but I'm not taking him down
so as if he pushes I just neutralize
right so this this is me taking him down
and you'll you'll feel the pressure
right you feel the pressure
and all I'm doing is just neutral I'm
this neutral same thing you want him
over here that's when you start going
like this instead just be in that
relationship when this hand is telling
you what to do that's all you're doing
we're going to adapt it see how I'm
doing that neutralize you just following
that zero zero zero
zero zero zero okay let's try it
[Music]
and then here you can see that if I use
the distal end of the lever
that'll be closed with a neutral okay so
here you see how he's out but he's going
this way from this content like this
content not from this card that would be
+1 pull okay so it's just here you don't
have to go stay there if you want but
he'll go with me because I generating
that gravitational or that friction or
that reverse energy right I don't care
what what you call it
and
don't go racin okay Joe not here this is
enough contact this is enough contact
and so he's bracing their but as I start
to turn this right his center of gravity
is going to see do you see that but I
don't have to do it like this I can keep
the descent and the rain and the idle
and the relaxation helps me so I don't
have to go to plus one
[Music]
get up let him up right here's where you
want the
[Music]